JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello,
and welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
We have a very exciting
show for you today.
In fact, it's a little
more exciting
than what we expected.
We are having a special guest
joining us from Helsinki.
His name is Jussi Laakkonen.
And he's the founder and
CEO of Applifier.
How are you doing, Jussi?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: I'm
doing very well.
Thanks for having
me on the show.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank
you for staying late.
I know it's late here
now in Helsinki.
But we are very honored to have
you on our show because I
understand that the Nordic
countries is where the action
is in mobile nowadays.
Is that true?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Well, there's
definitely a lot of excitement
in the area.
You have companies like Rovio,
Supercell, King, and a number
of others that are creating
great games in the region and
certainly kind of a break
out, if you will.
Think of a region of just
15 million or so people.
And basically, all the top
grossing spots on iOS are
being covered by Nordic games.
So it's a great time to be
here working on games.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So it's a great segue
to my next question.
How did you come up with
the idea behind
Everyplay and Applifier?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Well Jarek, I
asked myself, how do I find
games for our mobile device?
And, of course, I can
go to the app store.
But it's pretty crowded.
And it's kind of created
by somebody else.
And when I really thought
about it, the answer was
pretty obvious that the best
games I ever found came
through a friend.
I ask a friend.
A friend tells me.
Or even better, a
friend shows me.
This is how I discovered a game
called Flight Control
like three years ago.
And I'm still playing that
game after three years.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, great.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: But the
challenge with having a friend
pick up an iPhone and say like,
hey Jussi, you really
got to play this game, is that I
actually need to meet you in
order to see that.
So Everyplay is really about
taking that moment, oh gee,
this game rocks.
I want to show everyone.
Or I'm doing so well
in this game.
Look at me.
And taking that moment and
making it shareable
by posting it online.
So that's what Everyplay
really is.
It's about digitizing word of
mouth and making it shareable.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
traditionally, this type of
sharing use case has already
been done in console
games and PC games.
We have a lot of that type
of content on YouTube.
It's extremely popular.
So how is mobile different?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Mobile
is different in a
good number of ways.
First of all, these devices are
considerably lower power
than your average high-end
PC gaming rig.
On a PC, you have quite a lot
of horsepower to spare for
video recording.
Whereas on a mobile device, it's
actually a pretty hard
engineering problem to
make it go fast.
Also what's very different from
PC is that on a PC you
can actually download a separate
software, like Fraps,
to record another software.
Whereas on an iOS
and Android, the
applications are sandboxed.
What this means is that another
application cannot
access the contents of
another application.
So you actually cannot have
a general purpose
screen casting tool.
Instead, what we do is we
provide an SDK that's easily
integrated into the games and
provides a seamless instant
replay and sharing solution.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
So is it fair to say that for
most of the PC titles today,
the videos that we see on
YouTube are basically captured
using third party software,
edited locally, and then
uploaded to YouTube?
Whereas with mobile, the way
forward is to really
incorporate this functionality
directly into the game?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: That's
absolutely true.
And it's a function of the
limitations or say
restrictions and protections
of the iOS and Android
operating systems.
And also I think what's
interesting, as you mentioned,
it's very popular.
Let's Play videos are
hugely popular.
And walkthroughs as well as
reviews by user are extremely
influential on YouTube.
And what that really speaks to
is that even though making of
these videos is not trivial, you
need to have the software.
You need to record and edit
separately and then upload.
There's a lot of people
doing it.
And what we are aiming to do for
mobile is to simplify this
by making it a completely
transparent part of the game.
So you play the game.
And you get a replay.
You don't think about that, oh,
I need a tool for this.
Or I want to do a replay.
Instead, you just get it.
And you can easily share
it or comment on it or
put it out to YouTube.
And I think that's really going
to unlock a number of
creators that would not have
done it on PC because the
tools were too complicated.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So the discover use case and
distribution use case is
definitely very important.
And I can totally see how this
is going to help mobile game
developers.
So maybe we should switch gears
now and have you show us
a little bit more about
your product.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Definitely.
So let's jump into a screen
share from my iPhone 5.
And hopefully this
comes through.
So I'm going to show you
a demo of a very
high-end Unity 4 game.
And I apologize in advance that
this is going to be a
little choppy over hangout.
This actually runs
at 30 frames per
second on my device.
So right now we are not yet
recording this game.
And as I tap this button, we are
now recording this game.
And there's actually zero
difference on the frame rate
on this game.
And we cannot really see it on
this live hangout because of
the way hangouts work.
But I encourage you to
go to everyplay.com
to see it for yourself.
So I'm going to stop the
recording now and open up our
editor user interface.
So the editor here shows the
replay that was just captured.
And we can even comment on
that by adding a forward
facing camera that actually
shows me.
So this is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm in a Hangout that shows
me from my iPhone
AirPlay to the Hangout.
So this is ability for us to add
a video commentary by the
player himself into the
game he's playing.
It's actually very exciting
because that takes the video
of the game play into
a personal story.
So this here was Unity.
We also work with a number
of game engines.
You can use Everyplay with
Cocoas a custom engine.
And most recently we've actually
added support for
even Unreal Engine.
And unfortunately, I don't have
the demo for an Unreal
Engine game on my phone.
But instead, I want to show you
a very popular game right
now called Nimble Quest.
And Nimble Quest is made by a
company called NimbleBit who
are best known for games like
Tiny Towers and Pocket Planes.
They are a small studio out of
San Diego where they've been
extremely successful.
And this is their latest game
that was featured by Apple and
is out today actually
on Android.
So you should get it from
the Google Play Store.
So this game plays a little like
the original snake game.
And this may be a little
small on the screen.
But what happens here is that
I'm controlling this snake
made out of my heroes.
And I'm trying to kill
the monsters.
And as I move around, this game
is actually capturing the
replay as it happens.
So there is no action the
user needs to take.
Instead, the capture is
done automatically.
And now, just for the purpose
of this demo, I'm going to
kill my snake and die
here miserably.
And you can see on the top
left-hand corner, there's a
button called Share Replay.
And this is the replay of the
game play we just created.
So it was captured in the
background while the game
played without performance
impact.
And now as the user, I can
easily share this with my
friends and other game players
through Everyplay.
So we're going to do that
now live on air.
So I'm tapping on
Share Replay.
And this opens up Everyplay.
And this is the Share screen.
So we're going to give
this a title.
Let's say YouTube Developer
Live On Air.
And let's use a hashtag to
organize this contact.
We'll call it Jarek because
this is a fan to
be there for Jarek.
And we're going to share it to
Facebook, Twitter, YouTube.
I'm not going to send this in an
email because you all know
how email sharing works.
But we'll see it being shared
to all distributed networks.
So I'm going to tap on Share.
And what happens is that the
upload starts in the
background.
And now I can share
it to Facebook.
And I'm going to share this
publicly on Facebook.
And we can post it.
And we're going to send it out
as a tweet, going live
on air right now.
And because I was already
connected to YouTube, this
actually has been uploaded
to YouTube also.
So right now we're looking at
Everyplay's social interface.
So this is me on Everyplay.
We use a nickname system with
the follower paradigm.
So here are people I'm following
who follow me.
And here's my previous
actions.
So I'm going to go out and
demonstrate a little bit about
Everyplay's social functions as
the video is being encoded
on our servers.
So this here is my home
feed, people I
follow, and their actions.
So I can see the replays
from cool games
that they're playing.
So let's find out something
interesting here.
Let's see.
OK, here's a BMX game.
So let's check out this game.
So we're currently streaming it
down from our servers and
then playing back on my iPhone
and then playing back to you
over the hangout.
So here's a BMX game.
This was captured by another
player, shared on Everyplay,
potentially Facebook, Twitter,
and YouTube.
And we can see the game play
right here on Everyplay.
And we provide a number of
social functions like ability
to comment.
And so that's my comment.
I misspelled it nicely.
You can obviously Like videos.
You can re-share videos.
So if you find something cool, I
could re-share it to YouTube
under my own account.
And obviously, because everybody
is geared towards
discovering content, we also
provide an app store but on a
straight beam social
interface.
And you can just install the
game that you've discovered
straight through Everyplay.
And also for game developers who
provide an ability to do
community management through
Everyplay, so this is the
games community management
page.
All the videos that have ever
been shared from this game are
visible here.
And the community manager of
this game could also re-share
these videos to YouTube
or Facebook or
Twitter, for that matter.
So Everyplay provides basically
a fully flexed
social infrastructure around
mobile gaming and is geared
towards connecting the fans
of the games together.
So why don't we now see if my
video has completed encoding.
So here's the video that
we just uploaded.
Let's see if it's
been encoded.
There we go.
So it's been encoded.
And we can see it's YouTube
Developers Live
On Air hashtag Jarek.
And we are now streaming it down
from our servers to play
it back on this device.
And here it goes.
So this is the capture
we just did.
We uploaded while we talked.
And it's now live, available for
anybody to check out why
this game is cool.
And as you may recall, we
shared it to Facebook,
Twitter, and YouTube.
So let's first open
up Facebook.
And this is my personal
Facebook account.
So you can see all of
my gory details.
And as you can see here, we have
YouTube Developers Live
On Air featuring Jarek.
And we could watch the video.
See?
It's ready to go.
And you can click to download
from the app store.
And let's see if I have
Twitter open.
I don't yet have Twitter open.
So let's open up Twitter.
And I'm going to go
to my tweets.
As you can see, YouTube
Developers Live On Air.
We support also Twitter cards.
So you can play directly from
Twitter to watch this reply.
And of course, most
importantly, we
also support YouTube.
So I'm going to go into--
these are my uploads.
Now let's see if it made
it to YouTube.
Yes, it made it to YouTube.
But it says that this video
is being processed.
So that's on YouTube.
The videos already
been uploaded.
But we can watch an earlier
upload I did from Nimble Quest
as I was testing this about
10 minutes ago.
So here's the replay.
So this is a very seamless
system that enables the
players to share their best
replays, connect socially on
services like YouTube,
Facebook, and
Twitter within Everyplay.
And that's it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Hope you
enjoyed the demo.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
this was great.
Thank you for doing this.
So let's talk a little bit more
about how this system is
implemented.
So can you tell us a little
more about the
technology behind it?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: So certainly
there are a couple of
components with this.
One is the SDK that goes
inside the game.
And that's a native iOS code
that we provide in the various
plug-ins for Unity, Cocoas,
Unreal Engine 3, and custom
game engines.
We are also hard at work with
our Android version.
And we hope to give you news
about that in the not too
distant future.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That
sounds great.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: That actually
captures the game play.
And then we have our server side
which runs on a Note GS
Mobile DB on the various
service and CDNs.
And basically, that's where the
videos are uploaded to.
And the whole social interface
you saw is all HTML5.
So there is no separate
Everyplay app right now.
It's all HTML5, all the social
stuff we looked at.
And we provide that on desktop
browsers, mobile browsers as
we looked at within Facebook
within Twitter.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, great.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: And then we
provide integration to
services like YouTube where
we upload the video.
It's always uploaded to the
user's own account on YouTube.
So we want the users
to be stars.
And so they can have them
on their own channels.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
Yeah, this is definitely the
approach that we recommend.
We also find that these videos
are more likely to go viral
because users have an incentive
to actually share
their achievements.
So this fits the use
case quite well.
So how do you use
the YouTube API?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Excuse me.
You were breaking up a little.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: My question
was, how do you use the
YouTube API?
Can you tell a bit more
about how you use it?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: So we have
a server-to-server
connection to YouTube.
So we use that for--
first, the user authenticates
himself with OAuth2 to
authenticate that he has
a YouTube account
and ability to publish.
And we store that access
keys after that.
And as we have the video on
the server, we use our
server-to-server integration to
YouTube service to upload
the video after it's been
encoded on our service.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Got it.
So the token is obtained
on the client.
So this is something that the
OAuth flow is executed on the
mobile device.
And then the refresh token is
sent to the server side.
And then the video is uploaded
on behalf of the user using an
access token that is obtained
from the refresh token that
you have actually obtained
on the client.
Is that correct?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Correct.
That's correct.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: And we don't
directly uploaded from a
client to YouTube because
we also do
moderation on these videos.
And we have certain safeguards
in place to make sure that the
content is PG-13, if you will.
And that's why we do the
re-encoding on the server side
and the security checks on the
server side and then upload
from the service.
This also means that the user,
if he is sharing to multiple
services, he only needs
to upload once.
And as we provide a
services-like background
uploading, then the video upload
will complete even if
the user exits the
application.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then are you using YouTube
API v2 or v3 for the upload?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: We're currently
using version two.
But we're very excited by the
opportunity that version 3 is
opening up.
So we're very much looking
forward to migrating to that.
And we have big plans to
leverage the data API on
YouTube because I think there
are great things you can build
with that, play lists, do a
feature that kind of creates
the content of your channel.
And we're really on the
early stages of that.
We first wanted to enable
the sharing for players.
And now the next step is kind of
creating that content into
interesting playlists,
organizing that by games, and
enabling games to find
their audiences.
So we're excited about the
new version three API.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And I think the YouTube audience
will appreciate easy
way to find this content,
especially if you're talking
about [? queue ration ?]
and play list management.
I think that's all very
important for game developers.
Because once the content is
out there, how do you help
users find it?
And definitely the
[? queue ration ?]
is the right way
to approach it.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: We also
leverage metadata so our
developers can specify a number
of arrivals, some
public, some private, that's
used to navigate these videos.
And we also are publishing I
think most of that, if not
all, to YouTube.
And the goal is to really enable
rich search abilities
within YouTube.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So one question that I typically
like to ask is,
while you were developing
your product or the API
integration, was there anything
that surprised you,
like things that you really
didn't anticipate about your
users or about the API?
Any lessons learned that
you would be willing
to share with us?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: I think what
we did right is that we
actually got in touch with the
YouTube team pretty early on.
And a few of the [INAUDIBLE]
were actually covered in our
first introductory course,
like the authentication
flow and the best
practices for that.
If we hadn't known about those,
it probably would have
been something that we'd been
scratching our head around a
little bit.
But because we took the
proactive approach and we got
good support from the YouTube
Developers team, I would say
that we really didn't run into
anything that was kind of an,
oh, that's really weird.
But it's more like, hmm, OK,
I'll read the documentation,
which is actually what Google
really shines on in my opinion
is the documentation
is exemplary.
So we had actually
a very easy time
implementing the YouTube API.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good
to hear that.
I will definitely pass this on
to our colleague Andy who
works on our documentation, gets
a lot of praise for it,
and that he's doing
an excellent job.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: I wish
ours would be as good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So any API
features that you wish we had
and they're not there yet?
Like, what are the next
things that you think
we should be pursuing?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Well, I think
when you look at a lot of the
gaming videos, there's quite a
lot of annotations going on.
And that would be certainly
something eventually to be
able to allow players or
programs to annotate videos.
So that would be certainly
something that we would be
looking forward to do because I
think that doing it manually
for videos, this requires
more manpower than a
small startup has.
That is definitely, I would say,
on top of my wish list.
And there are almost always
improvements that
you can look for.
But that would be kind of
a thing I'm looking for.
And I think I'm very excited
to also see [INAUDIBLE]
live-streaming APIs coming out
and all the possibilities that
that opens up to content
creators.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So let's switch to
our questions.
I see we have a question
from a viewer live on
YouTube about Android.
And you touched about that
earlier in the show.
And the question is, when
is Everyplay going to be
available in Android?
I'm sure you get that a lot.
So anything to add to what
you've previously stated?
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: So we met
with a lot of developers.
I would say close to 1,000
developers at GDC last week.
And we had nearly 10
people in staff and
did a lot of evidence.
And if there were one thing that
was above anything else
that was requested
was Android.
The good news is that we are
already at a working prototype
on Android.
So things are running.
It's not [INAUDIBLE] hey,
we hope this will work.
We know it works.
And I think with Android the
key thing we're working on
right now is device
recommendation.
And there's quite a few very
popular GPUs on Android that
you need to support in order
to have a viable solution.
So our goal right now is to have
a broad enough support
that we can launch a beta
version of Android in not too
distant future.
Unfortunately, I cannot give a
time frame because every GPU
is a little bit of a challenge
of its own.
And getting to high enough
penetration on the kind of
devices that you would expect
people to be playing on, it's
something that we're
still working on.
So it's definitely I would say
our number one priority.
We are already on it.
The prototype is running.
Things are looking good.
And now we can just conquer
the fragmentation.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Thank you for this
detailed answer.
And I think we're all anxiously
awaiting Android support.
I'm an Android user.
So definitely would like
to try it out.
So another question is for me.
Is YouTube Developer
Relations hiring?
And the answer is, yes,
we are hiring.
Google Developer Relations as
well as YouTube Developer
Relations is hiring.
To learn more go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
And you can learn all about
it right there.
Well, thank you very
much, Jussi.
I know it's getting late
right now in Helsinki.
Thank you very much for
joining our show.
And then looking forward to see
the new features coming
out of Applifier and sharing
my game play with the games
that you have integrated with.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: And you're
going to be sharing on
YouTube, obviously.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Absolutely.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: And that's
going to be awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Thanks
for having me.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And thank
you for watching.
See you next week.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Bye.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Bye.